hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr mit dabei seid
in New York treffen sich in dieser Woche
die Staats- und Regierungschefs der Welt
bei den Vereinten Nationen auch der
ukrainische Präsident volodomir selenski
ist in New York und wirbt weiter für
Unterstützung für die Ukraine gegen den
russischen Angriffskrieg an der
bisherigen milliardenschweren
Unterstützung für die Ukraine wird
zunehmend Kritik laut vor allem aus
Ländern des globalen Südens vor der
südafrikanische Präsident ramafosa
kritisiert z.B dass so viel Geld für den
Krieg ausgegeben würde aber keine
Handlungen für die grundlegendsten
Bedürfnisse von Milliarden von Menschen
unterstützt würden selenski hat Russland
gestern in seiner Rede vor der UN
Vollversammlung scharf angegriffen seine
Botschaft wenn die Ukraine fällt könnten
andere Länder die nächsten sein gleich
redet wlodomir selenski vor dem UN
Sicherheitsrat dem mächtigsten Premium
der Vereinten Nationen und das schauen
wir uns gemeinsam mit Euch zusammen live
an schafft es selenski in New York seine
Kritiker zu überzeugen inwiefern
bröckelt die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine und welche Rolle spielen die
brickstaaten dabei auch das wollen wir
uns anschauen wie gesagt wir schauen
gleich zusammen live die Rede von
selenski und sprechen mit meinem
Kollegen Elm teveson der ist in New York
verfolgt die Geschehnisse dort für uns
und hilft uns das Ganze besser zu
verstehen und einzuordnen wie immer gilt
für euch Fragen und Gedanken zum Thema
könnt ihr gerne direkt hier im Chat
stellen oder ihr schickt sie uns per
Mail an die Mailadresse die ihr jetzt
eingeblendet seht
zdfheute-li@zdf.de so und jetzt wollen
wir einmal uns auf den aktuellen Stand
bringen lassen und schauen wie die
Situation in New York ist und da wartet
wie gesagt mein Kollege Elm tevesson auf
uns hallo Elm grüß
Dich hallo nach Meinz wir warten wie
gesagt gespannt auf die Rede von
selenski er ist natürlich jetzt aber
auch schon ein paar Tage da wie hast du
ihn bisher in New York
erlebt also er war sehr leidenschaftlich
er hat ja eine Rede vor den verinten
Nationen in der Generalversammlung
gestern gehalten die sehr argumentativ
war es war eine glühende Anklage gegen
Russland der hat nicht geschimpft wie er
das in den Tagen davor in
Fernsehinterviews getan hat da hat er ja
Putin mit Hitler verglichen sondern hat
in der Rede Stück für Stück eine
Argumentation aufgemacht den Nationen
eben zu sagen dass Russland eine Art
weltkrieg organisiert der vielleicht so
noch nicht erkenntlich ist aber Russland
eben alles was möglich ist als Waffe
einsetzt beispielsweise Nahrungsmittel
indem er die Nahrungsmittel verknappt
durch die Blockade und dadurch den
Hunger verstärkt in der Welt Beispiel
Energie dass er dafür sorgt dass die
Energiepreise durch diesen Krieg in die
Höhe schnellen dass er Atomreaktoren ja
gewissermaßen in Geiselhaft hält und
damit möglicherweise auch eine nukleare
Katastrophe herauf beschwört und das
alles hat zelenski dargelegt als
Beispiel dafür dass Russland im Grunde
genommen eine Art indirekten Weltkrieg
hier führt und dass nicht nur die
Ukraine Opfer ist sondern eigentlich
alle Staaten die hier in der
Generalversammlung sitzen und deswegen
oder damit versucht er natürlich alle zu
überzeugen dass Russland weiter isoliert
werden muss und dass niemand mehr an der
Seite Russlands stehen sollte weil es
ein Aggressor ist der sich nicht nur
gegen die Ukraine sondern gegen die
ganze Welt richtet
mer jetzt war in den vergangenen Stunden
ein bisschen unklar ob der russische
Außenminister lavrov tatsächlich auch in
New York eintreten eintreffen wird und
dort sprechen wird vor dem
Sicherheitsrat oder ob er sich durch den
russischen Botschafter vertreten LZT
jetzt hören wir lavrov ist tatsächlich
in New York bedeutet er wird
möglicherweise auf selenski dann
tatsächlich treffen was ist von dieser
Begegnung deiner Einschätzung nach zu
erwarten also es ist interessant jetzt
gerade zu sehen da spricht der russische
Botschafter tatsächlich im
Weltsicherheitsrat wir sehen LAV selber
noch nicht und offenbar versucht der
Botschafter durch irgendwelche Einwände
zu unterbinden dass volodomir selenski
als einer der ersten hier in dem
Sicherheitsrat reden kann aber wenn
lavrowov nachher dabei sein sollte dann
wird er sich eben all die Vorwürfe
selenskis direkt anhören können und auch
müssen selenski hat ja gestern
angekündigt dass er auch konkrete
Vorschläge machen will in Ergänzung von
seiner sogenannten friedensformel das
ist ein Friedensplan über zehn Punkte
den er im vergangenen Jahr vorgestellt
hat und äh dem sich viele Länder der
Welt mittlerweile auch angeschlossen
haben da drin steht aber eben auch die
Formel dass die Ukraine in ihrer
territorialen Integrität
wiederhergestellt werden muss also
Russland müsste alle Gebiete zurückgeben
zelenski wird das alles sehr klar machen
vielleicht hat er tatsächlich einige
Punkte die neu und anders sind und dann
dürfte es sehr gespannt sehr spannend
sein zu sehen wie Sergei lavrov oder
wenn er doch nicht käme dann eben der
russische Botschafter darauf reagiert du
hast es angesprochen volodimir selenski
will heute neue Punkte in seinem
Friedensplan
vorstellen kann man da schon gibt es
Stimmen die du hörst oder Information
die an Dich herangetragen wurden was er
da konkret
vorhat also wir wissen auf jeden Fall
was er auf keinen Fall tun wird nämlich
dass er die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine in irgendeiner Weise aufgeben
würde was manche ja hoffen dass er das
zur Disposition stellt ob man
beispielsweise die Krim am Ende zu einer
neutralen Zone macht oder möglicherweise
Russland überlässt dem hat er eine
Absage erteilt er hat an Dienstag noch
ein Interview gegeben mit dem US-
Fernsehsender CNN und hat sehr sehr klar
gemacht diese territorialen Fragen sind
auf keinen Fall in irgendeiner Weise
Verhandlungsmasse er besteht darauf dass
die Ukraine in ihrem Territorium
wiederhergestellt wird so wie das im
Jahr 2011 war das heißt also lange vor
der annextion der Ostgebiete lange vor
der annextion der Krim das ist also
keine Grundlage für neue Vorschläge aber
wir hören dass hinter den kolissen ja
eifrig verhandelt wird schon seit
Monaten über die Frage der
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
wenn der Krieg irgendwann beendet ist
und in dem Zuge diskutiert und berät man
natürlich auch darüber welche Garantien
könnte man möglicherweise Moskau geben
wir erinnern uns für Putin war ein
wesentlicher Punkt dass die NATO ich sag
mal nicht zu nah auf Russland Grenzen
aufrückt durch eine Mitgliedschaft der
Ukraine wenn man in dieser Frage einige
konkrete Punkte hätte vielleicht wäre
das ein Ansatz vielleicht nicht Putin
tatsächlich an den Tisch zu bekommen
aber Russland weiter unter Druck zu
setzen weil man ja sagen kann guck mal
wir kommen euch ein Stück weit entgegen
aber ehrlicherweise ist das
Kaffeesatzleserei wir werden erst wissen
was selenski tatsächlich konkret
vorzuschlagen hat wenn er gleich hier im
Sicherheitsrat redet Elma wir bekommen
dabei dazu auch schon fragen bei YouTube
und zwar fragt ein User wenn es den UN
den Vereinten Nationen nicht gelingt das
Vetorecht einzelner Staaten zu brechen
bleibt die UNO weiterhin bleibt die UNO
weiterhin das schlechteste
unverzichtbare bzw hat das Vorhaben denn
überhaupt eine Chance was vermutlich
gemeint eine eine diplomatische Lösung
in diesem Konflikt zu
finden ja ehrlicherweise muss man sagen
dass die UNO immer noch das bestmögliche
aller Instrumente ist weil man in vielen
Fragen ja auch Einigkeit spelen konnte
in den vergangenen Jahren und
Jahrzehnten aber in solchen Fragen ist
es eben extrem schwierig und deswegen
fordern ja manche auch eine Reform des
Weltsicherheitsrates damit nicht ein
Staat in der Lage ist und das sind ja
gar nicht alle im Sicherheitsrat sondern
nur ganz wenige die ein Vetorecht haben
dass dann einzelne Staaten in der Lage
sind am Ende alles zu blockieren
deswegen hat man ja in der Sache Ukraine
in der Vergangenheit den Weg gefunden
über die Vollversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen klare Resolutionen zu
verabschieden mit über 140 Staaten die
tatsächlich diesen Krieg verurteilt
haben Russland auch als Aggressor
verurteilt haben da sind nicht alle
dabei da sind einige wenige die nach wie
vor Russland den Rücken stärken aber es
ist interessant zu sehen dass eine der
wichtigsten
Vetomächte im Weltsicherheitsrat gar
nicht auf höchster Ebene hier vertreten
ist es ist nicht der chinesische
Präsident jiin Ping dabei und es ist
auch nicht der chinesische Außenminister
dabei der hält sich gerade in Moskau auf
die fehlen natürlich um Russland den
Rücken zu stärken vielleicht ist das
auch ein Signal dass in China man
skeptisch der Fortsetzung dieses Krieges
gegenüber steht also man hat erstmal nur
den Weltsicherheitsrat aber je nachdem
wie Russland sich heute hier verhält und
wir sehen jetzt gerade wie darüber
beraten wird was der russische
Botschafter gerade eingebracht hat wo er
möglicherweise die Rede von selenski
ausbremsen will
wir sehen wie dann eben die
Generalversammlung die anderen darauf
reagieren und wenn sich noch mehr finden
als die 140 ähm das zu verurteilen was
Russland da tut
äh wenn einige von seinen bisherigen
Verbündeten von ihm abrücken dann bietet
das Chancen weil am Ende eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit in der
Generalversammlung auch ausreichend wäre
um bestimmte Aktionen zu beschließen z.B
eben auch Konferenzen voranzutreiben
Friedenskonferenzen also insofern kommt
viel darauf an wie Sergei lafrov wie der
russische Botschafter hier heute
auftreten
Emmer ich habe es Eingang schon gesagt
zelenski ist natürlich in New York um
weiter für Unterstützung für gegen gegen
den russischen Angriffskrieg zu werben
und natürlich auch die Kritiker die in
Teilen immer lauter werden was die
Unterstützung angeht zu überzeugen wen
muss er da vor allem überzeugen wer sind
die die diese Unterstützung zun demm
kritisch
sehen also es gibt einige die muss er
nicht überzeugen das sind Länder wie
Iran oder Nordkorea die dicht an der
Seite eben Russland stehen die am Ende
da keine Hauptrolle spielen es sind vor
allen Dingen Länder des globalen Südens
die ich sag mal sich zwischen den beiden
Seiten befinden die der festen
Überzeugung sind dass erstens dieser
Krieg natürlich der weiteren Entwicklung
der Welt hinderlich ist eine Menge
Nachteile erzeugt für die gesamte Welt
dass auch diese nachhaltigkeitsziel über
die man hier ja Montag beraten hat in
New York dass diese eben ausgebremst
werden weil dieser Krieg alles
überschatt
das sind Länder wie Brasilien wie Indien
Indonesien andere große Staaten die auf
der einen Seite der Meinung sind dieser
Krieg stört die auf der anderen Seite
aber auch der Meinung sind dass der
Westen dass die NATO dass die großen
Industrienationen die sich gegen
Russland und China stellen dass diese
großen Staaten auch ein gutweit ein
gutstück dazu beigetragen hat haben dass
es eben zu diesem Krieg gekommen ist
Lula da Silva der Präsident Brasiliens
gilt als einer dieser Kritiker der eben
sagt immer weitere Waffenlieferungen der
NATO an die Ukraine würden den Krieg ja
nicht bald beenden sondern im Grunde
genommen weiter befeuern so die gilt es
zu überzeugen und wir hatten hier
gestern so etwas wie ein Speeddating da
haben sich sowohl volodomir selenski als
auch Joe Biden als auch der
Bundeskanzler mit den Anführern solcher
Staaten getroffen unter anderem mit Lula
da Silva mit den Präsidenten und
Anführern von fünf zentralasiatischen
Republiken das hat Joe Biden gemacht
also Nachbarstaaten Russlands um die
überzeugen dass eins unerschütterlich
feststehen muss die territoriale
Integrität eines Staates ist unantastbar
so steht es auch in der Karta der
Vereinten Nationen und wenn alle das
ernst meinen dann müssten sie sich in
dieser Frage auch sehr eindeutig gegen
Russland Stellen
Emmer ich würde dir gerne noch einmal
eine Frage weitergeben die uns bei
Youtube erreicht hat und zwar fragt da
Stefan Schindler wie ließe sich denn
heute schon Russland zur Verantwortung
ziehen um reparaturzahlungen in der
Ukraine zu leisten wäre es möglich
Gelder ausländischer Konten hierfür
abzuleiten eine sehr spezifische
Frage ja also es sind ja tatsächlich
Gelder eingefroren russische Gelder im
Ausland und
das bekannteste Beispiel sind vielleicht
auch Gelder von Privatpersonen die auf
der Sanktionsliste stehen allen voran
einige russische
multimilliardäre Oligarchen deren
Eigentum festgefroren ist man könnte
hingehen und dieses natürlich nutzen
auch zu Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
und es dürfte spannend zu sehen sein ob
die Vereinten Nationen es schaffen
sicherlich nicht im Weltsicherheitsrat
aber vielleicht in der Vollversammlung
in diese Richtung eine Resolution zu
verabschieden wir sehen dass jetzt der
UN Generalsekretär guterisch das Wort
ergriffen hat er ist formell jetzt
tatsächlich der erste der reden wird bei
dieser sicherheitsratsitzung den Vorsitz
führt ja Albanien auch ganz interessant
dass Albanien dass sich als enger
Verbündeter der USA a sieht dafür
gesorgt hat dass eben gleich nach
guteris
selenski sprechen kann normalerweise
wäre er erst viel später im Sicherheit
Sicherheitsrat dran gewesen aber
Albanien als Vorsitzender hat das Recht
eben dafür zu sorgen dass ein briefer so
nennt sich das weiter vorne redet ein
briefer ist natürlich und der hat die
Nummer ein das ist der Generalsekretär
der Vereinten Nationen goterisch und
gleich nach ihm dafür hat Albanien
gesorgt soll dann eben bulodomir
selenski reden
wir haben mittlerweile auch die
Information bekommen lavrov der
russische Außenminister ist tatsächlich
eingetroffen und steht auch mittlerweile
auf der Rednerliste was wir auch hören
Elma das würde ich dich gerne noch
Fragen es soll im weiteren Tagesverlauf
bei euch ist es 6 Stunden früher als
hier bei uns im Deutschland spricht 201
Uhr jetzt zu einem Treffen im weiteren
Tagesverlauf wie gesagt kommen zwischen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski was
ist von diesem Treffen zu erwarten was
hörst du
da ja wir glauben natürlich dass
selenski noch mal dafür werben wird dass
die Ukraine dringend weitreichende
Raketen in diesem Fall Marschflugkörper
aus Deutschland das sind die
taurussysteme braucht das gleiche wird
er auch mit Joe Biden besprochen haben
und er will auch morgen sich in
Washington mit Vertretern des
amerikanischen Kongresses namentlich
auch mehreren republikanischen Anführern
treffen um dafür zu werben warum weil
die Ukraine die diese Waffen braucht die
Offensive geht zwar voran aber sehr sehr
mühsam und das wichtigste Ziel dass die
Ukraine bei dieser Offensive hat ist die
Nachschubwege für die Krim abzuschneiden
dafür zu sorgen dass im grundeum das
Kronjuwel das Wladimir Putin besonders
wichtig ist unter druckgät die
russischen Truppen dort unter Druck
geraten die die Krim ja auch nutzen
gewissermaßen als Ausgangsbasis für
Raketenangriffe und Drohnenangriffe auf
die Ukraine und für dieses unter drruck
setzen braucht volod selenski solche
weitreichenden Raketen er hat schon aus
London und Paris entsprechende Raketen
bekommen aber dieses Thema aus
Deutschland und USA reichen noch weiter
sollen noch besser sein
und dafür wird erwerben wir hören nur
gleichzeitig dass eine Entscheidung
darüber weder aus Deutschland noch aus
den USA heute oder morgen zu erwarten
ist das hat auch damit zu tun dass
US-Präsident beiden momentan in
Haushaltsverhandlungen ist mit dem
amerikanischen Kongress da fordern zwar
einige Republikaner auch er sollte doch
bitte die Raketen jetzt liefern aber er
will sich die glaube ich noch ein Stück
weit als verhandlungschip aufsparen er
will erst dafür sorgen dass er weitere
13 Milliarden an Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine vom US-Kongress im Rahmen dieser
Haushaltsberatungen genehmigt bekommt
und dann so hören wir ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit extrem groß dass sehr
sehr schnell auch diese attackens diese
weitreichenden Raketen aus den USA
geliefert werden und dann stellt sich
natürlich auch die Frage wie dann
Deutschland wegen der taurussysteme
ich würde vorschlagen du hast es gerade
schon gesagt es spricht gerade vor dem
UN Sicherheitsrat der Generalsekretär
guterisch im Anschluss wird dann die
Rede vom ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski erwartet ich würde vorschlagen
dass wir einmal in die Rede von guteres
reinhören was er gerade
sagt wir haben schlimme schockierende
Verletzungen der Menschenrechte gesehen
die dokumentiert worden sind durch
unagenturen willkürliche
Verhaftungen standrechtliche
Erschießungen meistens durch die
Russische Föderation Zivilisten
betroffen Kinder in Territorien unter
russischer Kontrolle oder Kontroll der
Russischen Föderation und diese
Menschenrechtsverletzungen sind sehr
weit
verbreitet
herr Präsident der Krieg hatte zu einer
Erhöhung der weltweiten
Nahrungsmittelpreise geführt Millionen
sind in Armut geraten seit Juli
2022 haben wir diese Auswirkung
Abbildern können durch eine Erklärung
Kön ein Abkommen zwischen der Vereinten
Nation der Russischen Föderation während
diesesinkommen lief zusammen mit dem
Memorandum zur Lieferung von
Nahrungsmitteln und
Düngemitteln sind die
Lebensmittelpreise reduziert worden
diese
schwarzmeherinitiative führte zu 30
Millionen Tonnen Getreide die geliefert
wurden und es wurde dadurch auch möglich
hil an Afghanistan zalia zu
liefern wir bedauern sehr dass Russland
se Teilnahme an der schwarzminitiative
im Juli diesen Jahres beendet
hat und Russland hat direkt danach
begonnen
ukrainische Speicher Vorrichtungen unden
der
zu bombardieren in den Getreide lagerte
diese Angriffe müssen
enden die zivile
Seefahrt im Schwarzen
Meer ist gefährdet worden dadurch ist
die ganze Region
destabilisiert die Lieferungen die
möglichen Lieferungen aus der Ernte der
Ukraine weiterhin
gelagert aber nicht
geliefert viele derer deren guter Wille
notwendig ist im privaten
Sektor kann jetzt nichts
erreichen im Rahmen der schwarze beär
Initiative die
Exporte von Nahrungsmittel und Dünger
aus der Ukraine müssen wieder auf eine
stabile gesetzt werden ohne Androhung
von
Gewalt und wir bitten alle
Mitgliedstaten unsere Anstrengungen zu
unterstützen Richtung herr Präsident die
Vereinten Nationen arbeiten weiterhin an
einem gerechten und dauerhaften Frieden
in der Ukraine im üereinstimmung mit der
KA und dem Völkerrecht und die
Entschließung der
Generalversammlung
weitere lass uns gerne seit haben wir
jetzt gerade kurzen Ausschnitt gehört
von der Rede vom Generalsekretär
guterrisch lass uns gerne noch einmal
kurz sprechen über dieses Format was
geht tatsächlich welche Signalwirkung
kann von dem was da gesagt wird im
im UN Sicherheitsrat so ist richtig
tatsächlich
ausgehen ich glaube wir haben gerade
schon ein bisschen Gefühl dafür bekommen
weil guteris ja einfach mal aufgelistet
hat welche Auswirkungen dieser Krieg auf
andere Länder in der Welt hat was
speziell eben Nahrungsmittel Engpässe
angeht was Hunger angeht was
möglicherweise auch Preise für
Nahrungsmittel aber auch für Energie
angeht und ich
glaube weil wir weil wir jetzt sehen
entschuldige bitte dass selenski anfängt
zu sprechen da wollen wir einmal gerne
zuhören danke dir
ja Herr generalretär meine Damen und
Herren
нуло в
574 до бо вра
боротьсясялюйнво агрея ро про
на на захоп
haben wir etung oder
nicht вы
ату укра с пра
на die Ukraine übtcht auf selbstverteung
знача допомага захища
статурелюесамле підтр фактди джерело
мце ого не зло для рос але са
ситуа
в глухому
пу агре людстваже не покладае на на ко
де про захист суверенх кордо на де світу
шкаю но майданчики альян я
молимен
катастрофч проблем які тут у х нах
зустчаю торику а
нешенустчаютпрагне
компроми жия жияр
бекомпросно а за ус а я негодтут я
украна не мала
про са конх
ра высту перед гесамлею я сказа про
укран форла
рула на мож модерзува на архітектуру
безпе
тких
пра хочу представи деталі конкрет важли
на осно форму
дек пй формула руго назва выконання
статуту и стого
поряд все сте са
ротьздат нажаль іўцму клі в радпе я раія
займаеконна
лі манираянгоя
та так
ге россия ин
то распеки то генасамблеи я могли бы
зупинити цю агресю розбиваються о
привилей який да крсла
агре в руках агресара ось те что загнала
оон
глухй якою наю не народом я налит льонів
людей а малою наю наю яка
за
сле аною
незалежно допомогн державою яка потбуе
допомо націю яка може реально допомагты
државую яка
срается а таюржаву длякоту оон ар перю
та останню лінію оборони ким бы вы не
були наявна система оон робить вас все
одно у одно менше ніж право вето які е ш
у кількох та які выкорыстоўваец одным
росю на шкоду всім иншим членам у цими
днями в асамбле дуже часто зву слово
нервні про
нерво
das ist diese Ungleichheit
wodurch die UNO ineffektiv der
Sicherheitsrat größte Plattform auf der
Welt ich glaube und ich weiß dass die UN
mehr tun kann und ich denke dass die UN
ker tatsächlich funktionieren kann für
den Frieden und die Sicherheit auf der
ganzen Welt aber dafür damit das
passieren kann müssen diese jahrelangen
Diskussionen und Projekte umgesetzt
werden in tatsächliche materielle
Prozesse der
unreform und das darf dabei nicht nur um
die Repräsentation hier im
Sicherheitsrat gehen und die Nutzung des
Veto das
braucht eine wichtige Reform das ist
etwas was wieder die
Macht der un-karte herstellen kann
500 74 Tage russische Aggression heißt
574 Gründe hier etwas zu verändern in
dieser Kammer die
Anzahl also
Billiarden werden dafür ausgegeben die
Menschheit möchten an der Welt ohne
Aggression Leben es gibt dagegen nur
einige Extremisten in Moskau die die
Welt überziehen wollen mit Hass mit
ihrem
Hass in den Vereinten Nationen gibt es
eine größere Unterstützung immer größere
Unterstützung dafür dass massenhafte
Verletzung der Menschen Rechte dazu
führen sollen dass vetore
Rechte aufgegeben werden müssen aber
Russland wird dieses gestohlene Privileg
nicht freiwillig abgeben die
generalversamung damit sie macht hat
dass Veto wirklich zu bekommen wäre das
der erste Schritt es ist unmöglich den
Krieg zu stoppen denn alle Anstrengungen
werden mit Veto belegt durch den
Aggressor und es ist notwendig diese
Frage in der Vollversammlung
anzusprechen zwei Drittel
der Woten unter können den Willen der
Asiaten der Europäer der Menschen aus
dem Pazifik aus Afrika wiederspiegeln
aus der mehrit der Welt sass das Veto
überkommen werden kann und das ist der
legale Weg vorwärts für die
Mitgliedstaat zweitens der
Sicherheitsrat muss voll verantwortlich
sein gegenüber den Nationen der Welt ich
bin für die Vorschläge verschiedener
Führer der Welt s vorgelegt haben
Sicherheitsrat die Vertretung der
sicherheitsratsmitlieder muss die
gegenwertigen
Realitäten widerspiegeln Milliarden von
Menschen haben keine ständige vertrung
im Sicherheitsrat die afrikanische
Einheit muss perent hier sein Asien auch
braucht ständige
Mitglieder und dazuen Länder wie Japan
Indien oder die islamische Welt bis
jetzt außerhalb der Ständigen Vertretung
im Sicherheitsrat sind
und die Veränderung in Europa müssen
berücksichtigt werden deutschland ist
einer der wichtigsten
globalen Länder die die Sicherheit
garantieren und wäre ein wichtiger
Beitrag Lateinamerika muss auch ständig
vertreten sein auch die pazifischen
Staaten müssen ständig vertreten sein im
Sicherheitsrat
aber wir dürfen nicht nur diejenigen
einschließen die in den Führungsstellen
sind in den Vereinten Nationen und allen
Unterorganisationen müssen alle
Mitglieder der Vereinten Nationen
vertreten sein die nicht als Aggressoren
gesehen werden und eine betteidigung der
bei der eine Verteidigung im
Sicherheitsrat muss aufgehoben werden
für eine Zeit wenn ein Mitgliedsland
Sicherheitsrat in unter Verletzung der
ker ein anderes Land angreift es ist
notwendig ein System zu haben Aggression
zu verhindern und rechtzeitig zu
reagieren wenn es darum gehtveränität
und die territoriale Integrität anderer
Staaten zu verletzen die Mitgliedstaaten
auf der ganzen Welt sollten sich zu
einem Mechanismus
entschließen der die Sicherheit aller
garantiert die russische Invasion der
Ukraine hat gezeigt wichtig so ein
Mechanismus
ist und man hätte gegen den Aggressor
vorgehen können nicht erst zum Stadium
als buscha passierte sondern auch als
Invasionsarmee aufgebaut wurde jeder der
einen Krieg sten will muss bevor er
startet sehen dass er verlieren
wird und Sanktionen sollten automatisch
im
Sicherheitsrat diskutiert werden wenn
irgendein Mitglied der General
Versammlung
Aggressor aggressiv reagieren
will die Ukrainer zahlen jetzt mit ihrem
Blut für das was der Sicherheitsrat
eigentlich tun sollte durch Abstimmungen
wir halten die Prinzipien der un-karte
aufrecht die territoriale Integrität ist
ein wichtiges Element der
Karter
und die Besetzung ist natürlich
Dynamit unter einer rechtsstaatlichen
internationalen
Ordnung große Schritte müssen ergriffen
werden für die Sicherheitsarchitektur
damit sie stärker wird die Ukraine kann
als Beispiel dienen ganz spezifische geh
dazu völlige Rückzug russischer
Truppen und Rückzug der russischen
schwarzmeerfotte und der Reste dieser
Flotte und der Rückzug aller Söldner und
paramilitärischer Formationen aus
Russland müssen zurückgezogen werden aus
dem
terorium der Ukraine wie 1991
konstituiert wurde effektive Kontrolle
der Ukraine über ihren gesamten Staat
und die exklusive Wirtschaftszone in
der im Schwarzen Meer z.bpiel nur die
Umsetzung dieser zwei Punkte kann zu
einer ehrlichen Beendigung vontigkeiten
führen die internationalen Institutionen
wurden ja nach Tragödien nach wichtigen
großen Kriegen aufgebaut wir sollten
nicht dafür warten dass die Agression zu
Ende Ben jetzt handeln wir sollen für
den Frieden
kämpfen das ist die ukrainische
friedensformel sie entspricht Prinzipien
der UN K diese Prinzipien die
Resolutionen die die Generalversammlung
angenommen hat das ist genau das was
es erlaubt dass die ukrainische
friedensformel real
wird die
Ukraine weiß dass sie für eine
regelbasierte internationale Ordnung
kämpft für den Schutz der Menschenrechte
und Schutz gegen
Aggression das
Epizentrum Maßnahme sollte in dieser
Kammer sein im Sicherheitsrat
nämlich und in großem Umfang in der
vollversersammlung das sind die
formellen Institutionen der UN und wenn
wir dazu eine Reform der UN Institut
Institutionen brauchen da sollten wir
keine Angst davor haben und wir wollen
mit der friedensformel auch in
entsprechenden
resolutionsentwürfen Arbeiten für eine
Reform die Ukraine
Ruf die Nation der Welt auf sich für die
Umsetzung der friedensformel einzusetzen
jedes Land kann im
Rahmen einer oder mehrerer Punkte der
friedensformel
unterstreichen es gibt verschiedene
Punkte
friedensformel die
Sicherheitsberater ders
Länder bekommen eine Liste von Punkten
die umgesetzt werden müssen um die
friedensformel umzusetzen wir hoffen
dass auf dies separater Ebene
entsprechende Gespräche gibt auf der
Grundlage der zehn Punkte der
friedensformel und dann später
Gipfeltreffen mit politischen führen und
später könnte das dann von den
entsprechenden Staatschefs auf
entsprechenden Gipfeln diskutiert würde
werden
alle Mitgliedsländer können an der
Wiederherstellung des Friedens
mitarbeiten das ist wichtig für die
Ukraine und für die Völkergemeinschaft
der Friede möge obsiegen und mögen
unsere Institution und unsere
Zusammenarbeit stärker werden vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und danke
für die Möglichkeit dass ich sie
ansprechen durfte danke für die
Einladung vielen Dank
und libe Ukraine
ich danke soweit der ukrainische
Präsident volodomir selenski vor dem UN
Sicherheitsrat in New York wir wollen
darüber jetzt noch gerne einmal ganz
kurz sprechen mit meinem Kollegen Tison
der in New York auch diese Rede für uns
verfolgt hat Elm da waren ja jetzt
einige Punkte drin lass uns gerne
vielleicht einmal kurz über das von
selenski auch angesprochene Vetorecht im
Sicherheitsrat sprechen was genau hat er
dazu gesagt
ja ich sag's mal unter der Überschrift
keine Kompromisse mit Killern so hat er
es ja tatsächlich ausgedrückt das heißt
erfdert dass im Weltsicherheitsrat die
Frage des Vetorechts reformiert wird
dass man in der Lage ist entweder das
Vetorecht komplett abzuschaffen für eine
Reform der Vereinten Nationen oder dann
das Vetorecht suspendiert in Situationen
wo der der das Vetorecht eigentlich hat
eben beteiligt ist an einer Aggression
oder sie durchführt und vor diesem
Hintergrund dann ja so parteiisch ist
dass er eigentlich dieses Vetorecht
nicht mehr haben dürfte um alles zu
blockieren das was er da gemacht hat ist
im Grunde etwas was in der öffentlichen
Meinung hervorragend ankommen wird weil
er es verbunden hat mit einer großen
Reform der Vereinten Nationen wie sich
viele das eigentlich wünschen die sich
auch darüber aufregen dass nicht nur
Russland sondern auch China und vor
allen Dingen die USA ein Vetorecht immer
haben in allen Fragen aber es wird nicht
einfach umzusetzen sein weil diese Staat
müs am Ende mit dazu beitragen dass das
getan wird und dass am Ende in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen eine zweirittel Mehrheit
ausreicht um solch einen Beschluss über
eine Suspendierung oder eine komplette
Abschaffung des Vetorechts dann eben
auch zu
fällen vielen Dank er tiisson für deine
Einschätzung und Eindrücke aus New York
danke dir für den Moment so und wir
wollen uns das ganze jetzt noch weiter
einschätzen lassen und ich freue mich
dass ich darüber jetzt sprechen kann mit
der Politikwissenschaft
Liana fix die mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist
ich hoffe wir können Sie gleich sehen da
ist sie hallo Frau fix grüße sie hallo
schönen guten Tag sie haben die Rede von
selenski auch gerade verfolgt wie war
ihr Eindruck von dem was er da
vorgetragen
hat ja hat eigentlich drei interessante
und cleverere Argumente gemacht aus
seiner Perspektive zum einen hat er
argumentiert dass sich die UN in der
Sackgasse befindet aber auch Vorschläge
gemacht wie sie reformiert werden könnte
und da i auch wichtige Länder wie z.B
Deutschland Brasilien oder eben auch die
Afrikanische Union mit einbezogen das
heißt er hat einen breiten Konsens
versucht zu bauen auf der anderen Seite
hat er versucht dem Eindruck
entgegenzuwirken dass die Ukraine
kompromisslos ist dass sie auf alle
Fälle die die Gegenoffensive durchsetzen
möchte und nicht bereit zu Gesprächen
mit Russland wäre hat noch mal betont
dass es eine friedensformel gibt von
ukrainischer Seite und diese ganz eng
mit den Werten und mit den Regeln auf
den in das unsystem basiert verknüpft
und damit eben deutlich gemacht es ist
nicht so dass wir nicht reden wollen die
Frage ist nur können wir zu russischen
Bedingungen reden oder sollten wir zu
Bedingungen reden die die Bedingungen
der UN und den Prinzipien der UN
entsprechen Frau friix uns erreichen
dabei natürlich auch Fragen bei Youtube
und zwar fragt Jens K gerade das
Vetorecht im UN Sicherheitsrat muss
fallen erstmal eine Aussage kann man
denn kann man den nicht neu gründen den
Sicherheitsrat wenn die möchte dieses
nicht abschaffen
wollen ja das ist leider extrem
schwierig weil die UN eben nicht darauf
angelegt worden ist immer wieder neu
gegründet oder fundamental reformiert zu
werden es bräuchte zur völligen
Neugründung des Sicherheitsrat so wie es
ist bräuchte es wirklich eine große
Mehrheit der UN Generalversammlung der
Länder die das unterstützen würden es
würde im Prinzip bedeuten dass sowohl
die USA also Russland und China
überstimmt werden würden das entspricht
leider einfach nicht dem globalen
Machtverhältnis das wir gerade haben das
heißt die UN mit dem Veto im
Sicherheitsrat ist ein Konstrukt was was
sozusagen aus den 50er Jahren kommt
was stamen worden ist nach dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs und damit natürlich
überhaupt nicht mehr passt auf diese
heutige Welt aber es wird nicht gehen
indem man die jetzigen Vetomächte
einfach übergeht und etwas völlig Neues
ohne sie aufsetzt dazu sind die
Machtverhältnisse einfach zu
unterschiedlich verteilt in der Welt der
UN Sicherheitsrat gilt ja trotzdem als
das mächtigste Gremium der Vereinten
Nationen was kann er denn in dem Status
Quo also so wie wir ihn gerade sehen mit
den Machtverhältnissen dort tatsächlich
bewirken wenn wir auf dieses Thema
schauen ja das wird tatsächlich immer
schwieriger nicht nur weil Russland und
China die Zusammenarbeit intensivieren
sondern eben auch weil diese
Blockbildung zwischen den westlichen
Staaten auf der anderen einen Seite und
Russland und China auf der anderen Seite
immer stärker wird wo der UN
Sicherheitsrat noch funktioniert ist bei
Themen die nicht ganz so stark
polarisiert sind wie russlandskrieg
gegen die Ukraine also wenn es z.B um
sicherheitsmissionen geht auch da ist
die Zusammenarbeit schwierig aber da
kann tatsächlich noch auf einer
niedrigschwelligeren Ebene könen
tatsächlich noch
Zugeständnisse erreicht werden
gemeinsame Kompromisse geschlossen
werden aber bei den Themen die von
globaler Relevanz sind wie eben der
Krieg gegen die Ukraine wie eben auch
die Zusammenarbeit Russlands mit Chinas
ist es leider eine Frontstellung die wir
im Sicherheitsrat sehen und die sich
auch auf absehbare Zeit nicht auflösen
wird es wird ja neben Waffenlieferung
auch immer viel über eine diplomatische
Lösung dieses Konflikts gesprochen
Wolfgang Ischinger der ehemalige Chef
der München Sicherheitskonferenz hat
Ende März im ZDF gesagt es ist die
klassische Aufgabe des auswärtigenamts
für eine Bundesregierung mögliche
Verhandlungen vorzudenken man müsse
sagte er weiter sich überlegen ob man
auf bestimmte Forderungen Russlands
eingehen sollte lassen sich solche
Gespräche denn tatsächlich vorbereiten
so wie das der wie das Herr Ischinger
fordert ja es l sich selbstverständlich
theoretisch darüber reden unter welchen
Umständen Gespräche geführt werden
können welche Bedingungen welche
Kompromisse möglich sind das ist denkbar
das ist auch vorzubereiten die größte
Herausforderung die es gibt ist das
bisher von russischer Seite keine
Bedingungen vorgebracht worden sind die
auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise
kompromissfähig sind im Gegenteil
russland hat immer wieder bestärkt dass
es von seinen maximalzielen der
Kontrolle der Ukraine nicht abrückt
und das ist
aus ukrainischer Sicht natürlich ein
ein kein kompromissange Gebot sondern im
Prinzip eine Kapitulation zu russischen
Bedingungen etwas was eben auch die
westlichen Unterstützer der Ukraine
nicht eing gehen können und daran haakt
es am allermeisten dass es sozusagen
auch von russischer Seite noch keinerlei
Interesse gibt in Bedingungen
Bedingungen zu definieren die auch nun
irgendeiner Art und Weise für die
Ukraine ein Tor zu Gesprächen öffnen
würden und deswegen wird es auch
absehbare Zeit dabei bleiben dass zuerst
auf dem Schlachtfeld die Bedingungen
definiert werden und dann wenn auf dem
Schlachtfeld es kein Vorankommen mehr
gibt dann möglicherweise Bereitschaft
entstehen
wird Frau fix uns erreichen weiter
Fragen eine bei Youtube von Scarlett
Carson die fragt noch mal mit Blick auf
den Sicherheitsrat wie wahrscheinlich
ist es denn dass es in Zukunft eine
Ausnahmeregelung im Sicherheitsrat gibt
wenn ein Mitgliedsland ein anderes
Mitgliedsland angreift ist sowas
denkbar theoretisch sollte es denkbar
sein weil es natürlich die
offensichtlichste Verletzung jed
wiederch Normen der UN ist also die UN
interessiert sich ja in erster Linie nur
begrenzt um die inneren Verhältnisse
eines gewissen Landes als ob es eine
Demokratie ist oder ob es eine
Autokratie ist aber eine der
fundamentalen Regeln die die UN sich von
Anfang an gesetzt hat ist eben der
Respekt von von internationalen Grenzen
und dieser Respekt vor internationalen
Grenzen diese Verletzung von
internationalen Grenzen da gibt es eben
selten einen Fall in dem dies diese
Grenzen so klar verletzt worden sind wie
jetzt von Russland gegenüber der Ukraine
in dem Russland die ukrainischen Grenzen
selbst anerkannt hat nach
1991 und sozusagen verargumentiert dass
es das Recht hatte aus einem imperialen
Bedürfnis heraus diese Grenzen zu
verletzen also im Prinzip ist es steht
das so fundamental gegen die uncharte
dass es einen Mechanismus geben müsste
der allerdings nicht vorgesehen worden
ist eine solche Ausnahme zu zu schaffen
weil natürlich die fünf mit
Sicherheitsrat bei der Schaffung auch
ihrer Veto Möglichkeiten
jedwde jedw Situation vermeiden wollten
in der sie überstimmt werden in der sie
von den
anderen Mitgliedern möglicherweise
verurteilt werden also es ist die
Balance zwischen diesen fünf Mächten die
antiquiert erscheint heutzutage aber auf
deren Basis der Sicherheitsrat immer
noch funktioniert Frau fix ich würde
Ihnen gerne noch abschließend eine Frage
stellen wir haben gehört auch schon von
meinem Kollegen Elma tevissen heute
Abend im weiteren Verlauf dieses Tages
werden selenski und Scholz auch noch
aufeinander treffen es geht ja in New
York vor allem jetzt um die Suche nach
einer diplomatischen Lösung welche Rolle
kann und sollte Deutschland denn dabei
spielen ja Deutschland hat eine große
Rolle 2014 gespielt als Russland die
Krim annektiert hat und den Krieg in der
Ostukraine begonnen hat und 2022 wird es
sehr viel schwieriger für Deutschland
sein diese Rolle einzunehmen weil
Deutschland natürlich sich nicht als
neutrales Land einfach auf der
Seitenlinie positionieren kann sondern
die deutsche Unterstützung sowohl
militärisch als auch finanziell für die
Ukraine so wichtig ist dass Deutschland
natürlich auch auch von russischer Seite
nicht mehr als ein neutraler
Verhandlungspartner gesehen werden
möchte was auch völlig in Ordnung ist
weil Deutschland sich auch nicht als
neutraler Akteur in diesem Konflikt
positionieren möchte das heißt
Deutschland wird sicherlich kein
direkter Mediator sein so wie es z.B die
Türkei diese Rolle gespielt hat was
Deutschland aber natürlich tun kann ist
die Bedingungen zu denen Gespräche
stattfinden zu schaffen zum einen eben
dass Gespräche nur dann stattfinden wenn
sie nicht ausschließlich zu russischen
Bedingungen geführt werden das heißt
wenn die Ukraine weiterhin stark genug
ist um auch ihre eigenen Interessen und
Position durchzusetzen und dieses die
Ukraine stärken und auch in ihrer
Verhandlungsposition gegenüber Russland
Stärken etwas was Deutschland mit den
langfristigen äh mit den langfristigen
Hilfen militärisch und finanziell
jetzt jetzt für die nächsten Jahre
tatsächlich angelegt hat sagt die
Politikwissenschaftlerin Liana fix
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung Frau
fix danke
schön soweit unser ZDF heute live zu der
Rede des ukrainischen Präsidenten
volodomir selenski vor dem UN
Sicherheitsrat wenn ihr auf dem
Laufenden bleiben wollt aktuelle
Entwicklung verfolgen wollt dann schaut
am besten jederzeit vorbei in unserer
App ZD heute da findet ihr die
aktuellsten Infos und wir sagen für den
Moment danke fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten
Mal